[Musique]
bonsoir mercredi 13 mai bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv
depuis lundi le confinement a débuté en
france et dans les yvelines avec
notamment la réouverture progressive des
commerces en dehors des as bars cafés
restaurants pour lesquelles une décision
sera prise fin mai si la plupart des
grands centres commerciaux reste fermé
l'espace saint quentin a pu accueillir
de nouveau de la clientèle dès
aujourd'hui à montigny le bretonneux et
ce grâce à une autorisation de la
préfecture
70 % des commerces y sont rouverts dans
le strict respect des gestes-barrières
le reportage de marie lehn yapi shiloh
et de nicolas landry une réouverture au
public
oui mais dans des conditions strictes
établies à l'aide d'un bureau de
contrôle pour élaborer un protocole
sanitaire qui respectent les consignes
de distanciation sociale et d'hygiène
nous avons installé du mobilier qui
vient orienter les clients suivant la
destination il veut aller comme l'a par
exemple derrière moi vous avez une fille
qui part soit vers la pharmacie soit
vers la galerie et ensuite au sol des
marquages qui vient accompagné du coup
le client dans son dans son parcours
et pour entrer il faut porter un masque
comme l'indiquent la signalétique des
agents sont là pour contrôler et guider
les clients pour s'en procurer la
pharmacie a installé un stand pour en
vendre facilement aux clients qui n'en
posséderait pas les agents vérifier
aussi le flux de personnes limitées
autour des 2700 grâce à nos caméras de
comptage qui sont répartis un petit peu
partout dans le centre on a la
possibilité de connaître à l'instant t
le nombre de personnes qui se promènent
dans la galerie et du coup dès lors que
le seuil est à temps on reçoit une
alerte sur nos téléphones et notre boîte
mail nous signalant qu on atteint le
seuil et c'est là où du coup le rôle des
agents va être de bloquer les entrées et
on aura des fils qui vont s'organiser au
niveau des désaxés du centre d'un point
de vue viennent ou nettoyage et
renforcer les points sensibles comme les
rampes d'escalators sont désinfectés
toutes les deux heures et des
distributeurs à gels hydroalcooliques
sont mis à disposition des clients
priorité garantir les gestes barrière le
tout dans les changes avec les
commerçants pour les informer du
dispositif qu'on va les mettre face à
leurs magasins le long de l'heure
façade très régulièrement ils avaient
des informations de manière à pouvoir
déjà se projeter savoir un petit peu ce
qui se passait et puis se positionner
dans les dents le
dans tout ce processus global si
l'espace saint quentin a établi un
protocole sanitaire globale
chaque boutique et ensuite adapter sa
pratique dans cette enseigne de
prêt-à-porter le client commence par se
laver les mains
donc on a mis une petite affiche avec
les normes de sécurité qui explique 15
personnes maximum de nos magasins avec
une bonne distance et on a mis des
flèches pour pas et pour expliquer le
sens de circulation
les vendeuses essaye d'accompagner le
client tout au long de sa visite pour
qu'ils ne touchent qu'un minimum de
produits dès qu'il veut essayer
en premier lieu on lui explique on a 60
jours un délai de 60 jours pour faire et
c'est remboursement à la maison ce qui
nous évite nous de nous donner encore du
travail en plus parce que au moment de
la cabine il y aura toute une procédure
pour la sécurité et puis bon pour les
jeunes une cabine sur les huit est
accessible et désinfecter par les
vendeuses entre chaque client enfin si
le client ne souhaite pas acheter ce
qu'il a essayé le vêtement sera nettoyée
à la vapeur à l'aide d'un des trois
soeurs puis mis en réserve durant quatre
heures avant d'être remis en rayon
c'est beaucoup de temps consacrés à
l'hygiène en sécurité que ce soit
vraiment pour notre bien à nous mais
aussi pour le bien des clients ça
rassure le client de nous voir avec la
visière avec une masse qu on a du
produit nettoyant qui est vraiment
partout pour vraiment expliquer au
client qu'il est bien en sécurité chez
nous et qui peut revenir avec mon
plaisir des clients qui s'adaptent en
faisant parfois du repérage sur internet
afin de chercher une pièce précise
l'espace saint quentin a choisi d'ouvrir
ce mercredi 13 et non pas dès le 11 mai
pour laisser le temps aux commerçants de
s'organiser
70% des boutiques autorisés ont levé
leur grille et le chiffre devrait
s'approcher descente pour cent à la fin
de la semaine
autre centre commercial rouvert one
nation nous plaît sous voies qui
accueille à nouveau sa clientèle depuis
lundi et des mesures sanitaires ont été
mises en place gel hydroalcoolique à
l'entrée des magasins balisage
spécifique port du masque obligatoire
désinfection régulière du site et d
assainissement à la vapeur de vêtements
en boutiques sont aussi prévus plusieurs
magasins restent encore fermés sur place
les restaurants font de la vente à
emporter
les commandes sont possibles par
téléphone avec la réouverture des
commerces les librairies sont de nouveau
accessibles également et
ample avec le avait du canal à montigny
le bretonneux où les lecteurs sont au
rendez vous mélanie potier une affluence
inédite le pavé du canal ne s'attendait
certainement pas à recevoir autant de
clients pour son premier jour de
réouverture la librairie a doublé sa
fréquentation par rapport à un jour de
mai 2019 la littérature comme important
dans la vie de tous les jours n'est
encore prise en ce moment j'ai envie de
dire un peu s'évader voir un peu autre
chose que toutes les nouvelles mauvaises
en tout cas à la télévision la
réouverture de toutes façons de
librairie c'est toujours un point
positif parce que les livres c'est une
grande richesse
la commande que j'ai passé pendant les
vacances ouais c'était pour aider sa
voix c'est un magasin que j'aime bien et
du coup j'avais envie qu'eux ils
tiennent le choc
mais ici aussi les gestes barrières sont
de rigueur employés équipe et sens de
circulation à respecter des consignes
qui ne masque pas la joie des libraires
de redémarrer leurs activités
les gens vont vraiment nous envoyer de
mai nous embarque alors vous ouvrez on
sera la présence des premiers jours on
viendra vous voir on vient d'en discuter
avec vous ça fait du bien cet échange
mais pour nous voilà de revivre une vie
à peu près normale de livres aird de
rediscuter de livres de littérature de
science humaine de genèse plein de
choses de voir du monde
le confinement a laissé un impact
économique sur l'entreprise 10 salariés
ont repris sur les 15 employés par la
librairie les habitudes de lecture ont
aussi changé hier c'est la littérature
qui a pris son envol
plus de 150 ouvrages ont trouvé leurs
lecteurs un moment d'évasion en tournant
les pages d'un livre neuf des
réouvertures mais un département tire
est de couleur rouge sur la carte du
déconfinement comme pour le reste de
l'ile-de-france les yvelines où sont
survenus avec 456 décès liés aux
coronavirus dans les hôpitaux un de plus
en 24 heures le nombre
d'hospitalisations et de réanimation
baisse toujours 695 patients étaient
hospitalisés hier mardi sur le
territoire ces 23 en moins par rapport à
lundi et puis à 1650 personnes sont
désormais guéri est revenu à domicile
après un séjour en établissement
hospitalier sur le territoire
on le sait l'un des moyens efficaces de
réduire la circulation du virus est le
respect des gestes barrières porter un
masque notamment dans l'espace public et
a vivement recommandé par les autorités
elle est maire s'organise donc pour
fournir des protections à leurs
habitants à la verrière à 6400 âmes des
masques chirurgicaux ont été distribués
par des agents bénévoles dimanche
dernier et en début de semaine une
solution de dernière minute alors que la
ville attend toujours la livraison de
protection en tissu est de 12500 sont
actuellement bloqués à la frontière
franco suisse
la raison n'est pas connu plusieurs
transporteurs ne peuvent actuellement à
reprendre la route écoutez la réaction
de la mère nelly duthu on sait qu'on
n'est pas les seuls à avoir ce genre de
problème que ce soit par route ou par
avion
c'est un bloc dans tous les sens j'avais
dit en émoi malheureux d'autres puisque
d'autres villes se sont fait voler leur
propre stock
le fournisseur doit aller chercher lui
même des masques alors à la frontière
les va revenir avec on devrait avoir une
en basque en tissu vichy la fin de la
semaine
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
plusieurs maisons de santé se sont
réorganisés nécessaires pour continuer
aussi leurs activités médicales auprès
de leurs patients habituel cependant ces
personnes ne se sont pas déplacés en
consultation depuis plusieurs semaines
un phénomène inquiétant pour les
médecins notamment ce qui concerne les
maladies chroniques les explications
avec ce sujet de nicolas landry et
mathilde et demie chaque praticien va
chercher son patient à l'accueil donc ya
pas de gens qui attendent dans les
salles de toute une organisation
spécifique depuis le 16 mars pour
rassurer les patients habituels de cette
maison médicale
ces patients qui ont notamment déserté
les cabinets médicaux pendant le
confinement par crainte de contamination
certains sont parfois atteints de
maladies chroniques et ont besoin d'un
suivi régulier un phénomène qui inquiète
les médecins
on commence à voir les diabètes
déséquilibres et les tensions qui ne
sont plus équilibrés les les examens
usuelle qui n'ont pas été fait
on a même dû vraiment insister pour que
les petits notamment les nouveaux nés
soit vacciné lorsqu'ils n'étaient pas
vaccinés l'impression qu'on a c'est
qu'il va y avoir une crise sanitaire
liée aux que vides une crise sanitaire à
cause du coc vide et une crise sanitaire
à cause des problèmes psychologiques
liés au co vidéo confinement ont évité
tout contact avec le virus
une zone spécifique a été mise en place
pour recevoir les patients qu'ovide 10,9
les médecins généralistes prennent en
charge ces personnes suspectées
d'infection surblouse charlotte masques
ffp2 lunettes de protection nettoyage et
désinfection entre chaque consultation
toutes les précautions sont prises dans
cette zone on voit quasiment plus
personne là on est vraiment jamais vu à
la semaine dernière croit d'accord donc
ça c'est vraiment voilà c'est quasiment
disparu alors maintenant on a on a peur
de d'abord un ou deux cas isolés revenir
donc c'est pour ça qu'on la garde
ouverte au total depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire près de 400 patients
atteints du colis de dix neuf ont été
prises en charge dans cette maison
médicale dans l'actualité aussi ce feu
vert donné par le gouvernement les
conseillers élus dès le premier tour des
municipales le 15 mars seront en
fonction à partir de lundi prochain
entre le 23 et le 28 mai ils devront se
réunir pour désigner leurs maires et
leurs adjoints
un conseil dans le plus strict respect
de la distanciation physique avec une
limitation possible du nombre de
participants dans les yvelines 215 des
259 communes sont concernées 5 sur 12
dans l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines pour les autres un second tour
devrait être organisé deux périodes
évoquées pour ce faire le mois de juin
ou à l'automne
à partir du mois de septembre à
villepreux notamment les électeurs n'ont
pas réussi à élire un candidat dès le
premier tour une commune où le maire en
poste stéphane mirambeau tiendra un
conseil municipal demain jeudi il se
déroulera à partir de midi en
visioconférence à l'ordre du jour le
point sur la crise du coronavirus à
l'échelle de villepreux une séance
demandée par le groupe d'opposition
villepreux d'abord la loi permet en
effet à un cinquième des élus de
demander
tenue d'un conseil municipal un plan de
soutien au secteur touristique le
gouvernement doit le présenter ce jeudi
comment le secteur de l'hôtellerie dans
les yvelines vit-il cette période est
elle sortie de crise envisagées éléments
de réponse dans cet entretien mené par
wilfrid richy philippe papin président
de l'union des métiers et des industries
de l'hôtellerie dans les yvelines est en
ligne avec nous bonjour bonjour vous
caffier hôteliers restaurateurs et
exploitants d'établissements de nuit
vivent une situation catastrophique
actuellement avec toujours une fermeture
ont ce milieu du mois de mai aujourd'hui
si on doit faire un état des lieux dans
les yvelines
est ce que les établissements vous
pensez peuvent survivre à cette crise
ils vont tout faire pour et je crois que
évidemment avec le le les aides du
gouvernement je pense que c'est ce qui
est c'est le but de rechercher mais
après il ya toujours des des situations
qui seront plus pénible que d'autres
nous en tant que fédération et on fait
tout pour que ça se passe le mieux
possible avec des pouvoirs publics
l'activité a été réduite à zéro depuis
le 17 mars
en ce qui concerne l'hôtellerie déjà
qu'on précise minutieuse oui en dehors
des hôtels qui ont été réquisitionnés
pour raisons pour loger des soignants
des aides soignants ou du personnel
médical tous les autres chanteurs
l'hôtel des hôtels dont ont quasiment
tous fermés
et effectivement c'est un chiffre
d'affaires perdu qui ne se rattrape pas
donc c'est même une semaine avant le
confinement c'était déjà très haut très
ralentie depuis début mars
si on imagine les perspectives de
reprise aucune date n'a encore été
annoncée
le gouvernement doit dévoiler encore des
des mesures d accompagnement pour le
secteur touristique au sens large
pas uniquement pour l'hôtellerie si on
se projette sur la suite vous imaginez
un retour à la normale possible cet été
cet été je sais pas parce que nous on
est on est dans l'île de france et son
nez plutôt une zone urbaine où le gros
de la clientèle
deux semaines sont les les gens qui se
déplacent pour raisons professionnelles
donc les hôtels ouverts bien sûr
beaucoup d'hôtels ont rouvert lundi
ce lundi alors c'est sûr qu'ils n'ont
pas intérêt à plein de révélations très
remplie mais ils ont rouvert pour
accueillir parce que les développeurs il
déplacements professionnels sont
autorisés donc on peut espérer qu'il ya
un an et en plus on a été contacté par
la fédération française du bâtiment qui
recherche activement des chambres sur
toute l'île de france parce que les
chantiers repris et ça ça marche bien
j'étais en lien avec la direccte pour
lister tous les hôtels qui ont qui nous
ont dit rouvrir très immédiatement et
donc sont prêts à accepter ces personnes
qui vont intervenir sur les chantiers
mais sur la partie touristique
il ya aussi la son site une somme sur la
ville de versailles par exemple tout
l'attrait internationale que peut
susciter le château de versailles
là les choses vont être assez compliqué
à remettre en othe aussi absolument
puisque le château est toujours fermée
sera fermé à mon avis et le parc pas
encore moins jusqu'aux je sais pas je
n'ai pas de chiffres mais au moins
jusqu'à fin juillet donc je vous fais
route donc je ne sais pas donc ça va
évidemment sur le plan touristique ça va
être assez compliqué après bon nous
avons aussi des les petits musées averse
a aidé des centres qui vont qui vont
ouvrir mais évidemment c'est pas ça qui
va qui va relancer qu'il veut relancer
le tourisme comme avant c'est évident
que représentant du secteur de
l'hôtellerie dans le département des
yvelines à travers votre syndicat est ce
que vous avez eu le sentiment est ce que
vous l'avez aujourd'hui en tout cas
d'être accompagné par le gouvernement
par l'état par les assureurs aussi
peut-être votre syndicat était assez
critiques sur l'accompagnement des
assureurs aussi alors sur l'état où il
est l'amant voilà la confédération nos
élus nationaux ont été en permanence en
relation avec les ministères de bruno le
maire daniel spagnou rush et brooke et
un échange vraiment très très bon qui
est qui a été qui a été fait donc l'être
sur ce plan là oui je pense que c'est ça
s'est très bien passé d'ailleurs on peut
voir toutes les aides et les avancées
que fiscale que nous avons obtenus qui
sont quand même non négligeable et
assez unique en europe je pense donc oui
alors sur le plan des assureurs par
contre l'annoncé c'est le point noir
effectivement les assureurs ne jouent
pas le jeu et alors des négociations
sont en cours peut-être qu'il va y avoir
un retour mais pour l'instant c'est vrai
que c'est très compliqué avec eux et on
est enfin là la profession est vraiment
très en colère sur le court pour
conclure cet entretien vous parler de
ces hôtels qui qui sont en face de
réouverture depuis y est depuis le début
de la semaine pour certains avec une
reprise qui débute d'activité quelles
sont les normes sanitaires comment vous
mettez en place des normes sanitaires
strictes dans les établissements alors
pour l'hôtellerie donc il faut dire que
tout ce qui est restauration bien sûr
est supprimé puisque la lépi les petits
déjeuners seront uniquement servi en
chambre ou avec des plateaux qui seront
à disposition des clients dans le lobby
les on respectera bien sûr les
distanciation au niveau du check-in au
niveau des réceptions il y aura des
filles du rhin dès le personnel sera
équipée de vizir de masques de gants du
gel hydroalcoolique sera à disposition
des clients du personnel et il ya une
une séparation bien sûr strict du
traitement du linge sale et du linge
propre
par exemple les les gens qui quitteront
leur champ de noeuds pour les chocs qui
seront à libérer ne pourront pas être
reloué avant 24 48 heures on dit qu
étrange hr1 c'est à dire qu'on pourra
pas rentrer dedans avant 24 48 heures
donc pour les autres petits hôtels c'est
un problème
ensuite bien sûr il ya toute une
panoplie de 2-2-2 de consignes pour le
personnel des tâches qui sera qui seront
assez strictes oui mais sur place on a
mis ça en place en lien avec eux les
agences de santé à un coût est ce que ce
sera répercutée il y aura un coût
forcément de ce conte un hôtel ne pourra
plus être rempli à 100% puisqu'il faut
mettre des chambres en jachère on croit
ce sera
activité à 50% vraiment un minimum 50 ou
60% mais les hôteliers estime que
adapteront leur personnel enfin leurs
besoins en personnel en fonction de
l'activité et ça ça va durer un petit
moment malheureusement corde
je sais pas pour les coûts mais
forcément il y aura des coûts est pour
l'instant mené pas on attend les clients
merci philippe pas un président de
l'union des métiers des industries de
services dans les yvelines
grâce à vous en cette période où les
cinémas sont fermés votre rubrique dans
les salles devient un dans vos canapés
pour vous proposer des films à voir
directement depuis chez vous cette
semaine c'est la réalisatrice de
chevreuse et jenna sur rue qui vous
donne son conseil
le film que j'ai sélectionné pour vous c
est dieu créa la femme
le film de 1956 réalisé par roger vadim
pourquoi parce que déjà c'est un film
que j'adore c'est un film mythique à qui
est donc la première collaboration entre
roger vadim dans le premier vrai film
long métrage qu'ils ont fait ensemble
avec brigitte bardot
c'est un film aussi qui d'ailleurs a
fait beaucoup scandale aux etats-unis au
moment de sa sortie
mes 21 ans plus tard roger vadim a lui
même réalisé le remake américain
gottfried double peine est ce que
j'adore avec ce film c'est que
particulièrement en ce moment où film en
mai même aussi plutôt monde année on a
vraiment cette envie de voir des grands
espaces de voir le saint tropez des
années 50-60 ce saint tropez qui fait
rêver et cette paillade mythique avec
une cinématographie et des moments de
cinéma qui sont vraiment exceptionnelles
et qui sont toujours très très beau
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je comprends pas quel thème c'est
vraiment beau qu'un film mythique qui
aussi a marqué la période est donc c'est
celui que j'ai regardé d'ailleurs il ya
très peu de temps et que j'étais
sélectionné pour vous un film parmi tant
d'autres que vous pouvez louer ou
acheter sur les sites du centre national
du cinéma et de la ci n'était qu un
dernier mot pour vous dire que depuis
lundi les forêts yvelinois sont de
nouveau accessibles de déconfinement
permet de vous y rendre mais en
respectant toutes une série de règles à
deux rassemblements de plus de 10
personnes pratique sportive individuelle
autorisé tout comme les sorties des
associations et guide dans la limite
toujours des dix participants et pour
protéger les animaux sauvage préservée
de la présence humaine pendant deux mois
il faut tenir son chien en laisse et
roulez prudemment sur les routes à
proximité des massifs forestiers
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de l'avoir suivi demain
et vendredi c'est marylène iapichino que
vous retrouvez à la présentation de
cette émission belle soirée à tous
[Musique]